[Music]
and finally
gb news is starting at the weekend it's
chair and one of the presenters is
someone who might be familiar to a few
of you
hi andrew welcome back to spectator tv
for those that don't know could you tell
them a bit about what you've been up to
over the past few weeks
uh well in addition to my
responsibilities at the spectator i've
been
gearing up for the launch of gb news
britain's new
news channel which we hope is going to
launch if all the machinery will work at
the same time
at 8 o'clock on june the 13th which is
this coming sunday
from where we are now it's a joy to be
back on
spectator tv and really annoying to see
how well you've done
since i stopped appearing on it well i
can tell you that the viewers really
have
missed you andrew we still get quite a
few comments about it so i'm glad we
cleared that up and now you can tell us
what we should expect from
gb news when it launches next week is it
going to be obvious the ways that gb
news is going to set itself apart from
the other networks
i think it will i think people will
maybe take a little bit of time to get
used to what we're trying to be up to
what we want to be up to
but i think it will be different in two
ways
one is it won't be rolling news there's
enough rolling news around at the moment
that's basically what sky does and the
bbc news channel as well
and rolling uses repetitive and because
it repeats a lot
the ratings have never been high for
ruling news you
get great ratings if there's a gulf war
or a pandemic breaking out
but then once that's over the rolling
news ratings are cnn and sky
and others have found out gone down so
we are not going to be that we're going
to be
much more a series of programs starting
at six in the morning till midnight
built round presenters with a bit of
attitude and character
bees in their bonnet and so on so it's
not so much newsletters presenter
led with a wide variety of um
topics it's what american news channels
now do
from fox on the right to msn bc on the
left
and here's the news they do rate well
they do rate very well if you get it
right
and the second thing is that i think you
know i take the view don't
it's not really controversial but some
people get annoyed i think the existing
incumbents the people who
provide news and broadcast news in
britain sky
bbc channel 4 news itv
they pretty much all come
from the same stable of varying shades
of center-left attitudes
and in some it's almost like a one-party
state some
are more left than others channel 4 news
is more left than sky
sky these days remarkably i think is
more left than the bbc
uh bbc is a bit more left than itv which
is probably
the closest to the center and that
brings a set of attitudes
whether it's towards brexit or to cancel
culture
or even just an attitude towards britain
which is pretty much of a muchness and i
think we want to come
without going anywhere in the direction
of a fox news or anything like that
from perhaps a different agenda a
different set of assumptions
and looking at the world in a different
way outside that
cozy kind of tony blairish consensus
well social media is abuzz with the
launch and some people are already
convinced that they know exactly
what you're going to feature the tone
and the content of a platform that
hasn't
yet launched it must be very interesting
defending editorial decisions that
haven't been made yet
it's it's really interesting to defend
editorial positions that haven't been
made and i'm not quite sure what they'll
be
yet until we actually launch look the
buzzers have been fantastic about it i i
mean the one
you know whether it's positive or
negative i mean the the one thing
that you know i launched sky news as
part of the overall sky
package way back in 1989 and i do
remember
then it was the the attitude was a
combination either
of either hostility to the idea of a
news channel
particularly one owned by rupert murdoch
um or just indifference
you know what we need a news channel for
that that was actually true in america
when ted turner
launched cnn and i was with him the day
the week he launched cnn
and there was kind of indifference to
that too well we know what happened
there
this is very different there is a buzz
whether it's hostile or positive
there is quite a big buzz there's an air
of anticipation
uh about it as well and we have to
capitalize on
on that people are going to be
interested so we better give them what
they're looking for
and do it in a way that this is going to
make them
stick so people are to a degree i did
not foresee
kate people whether it's to smackers or
praises
they are waiting to see the launch of
this channel
it's a competitive industry made more
difficult for the newcomer by the fact
that the biggest broadcaster doesn't
have to compete the bbc has laws that
protect its income and a mandatory
license fee
if you own a television is the way that
news has been done before all these
structures these systems is that really
fit for purpose now especially as
um you know we have many more platforms
and people have so much more access to
what they choose to watch
well the bbc uh has its guaranteed
income which it tops up by over a
billion with its overseas sales and
commercial
uh ventures it i think it has a total
budget of about five billion
and even though its income is guaranteed
it does like to compete
uh i mean that sometimes paranoia's itv
or sky
but it does compete i mean you couldn't
really argue that strictly come dancing
was a pinnacle of public service
broadcasting but it's a hell of a
ratings winner for the bbc so they do
like to compete
look i think the the the current license
fee structure
is obviously not fit for purpose in the
decade that we've now
entered and there will have to be
changes what they'll be is not for me to
get involved in
uh i've got enough of my hands just
running you lot of the spectate
you lot of the spectator i mean that's a
full-time job that's like herding cats
on its own
never mind running gb news um
but i would say to the two things
uh british broadcast
news that's that's the police coming for
me by the way we probably haven't paid
the rent
of the new studios british broadcast
news
is among the best in the world uh and
and is
highly regarded all over the world uh
our our
british broadcasting whether it's the
bbc or sky or
itn one of the most famous names
in it or even channel four and their
documentaries
we are highly regarded uh as
broadcasters i would say among
the best in the world so that's been a
good thing and you know sky news was a
great addition the bbc
had to up its game sadly itv lost
interesting news that was a huge loss
because
when i was your age kate itn was a far
bigger news name than the bbc
music 10 on itv with my old mentor
alastair burnett
that was the newscast that mattered the
first half
hour newscast they were the first
double-headed newscast
massive ratings 12 million people in
these days used to tune in
but things need to change and
i don't think we can remain top of our
game without
reforms financing structures coming in
and changing and that's up to the bbc as
to how it goes forward with
charter renewal his biggest mistake
would be to think you should just try to
hold on
to the license fee as is there will have
to be changes
that's for them what i'm hoping we
to try and do is just bring a bit more
variety a bit
wider discourse a bit of a different
agenda
or even when we cover the same agenda to
come at subjects differently i'll just
give you a
general example there was a discussion
on the today program about a month ago
on the bbc
radio uh which and as you know like the
second world war kate
the whole pandemic business has made big
government fashionable again
and you know big government the second
world war gave us the athlete government
which certainly believed
in big government and mr johnson seems
to believe in big government too so the
today program of this clever idea
of debating you know is big government
here to stay
good subject except that all four people
that were on that discussion believed in
big government
well i think gb news might manage to
find at least somebody to say hey hold
on
the pandemic was the pandemic we need to
get back to
a more jeffersonian idea of more limited
government again it won't be easy but
that's what we're trying to do
it's just an example of it you will know
to the existing broadcasters
if there's a problem that they identify
in britain and boy
are they good at finding problems
sometimes problems don't even exist
but they're good at finding them they
come from a point of view which has
two suppositions in it one is if it's a
problem
it needs the government to resolve it
and secondly
if the government's to resolve it it
will need more money
so more government more money in some
cases
that may well be the way to resolve it
but not in every case
and i think we'll come at things just
that bit of a different way
which over time people will see is a
different kind of discourse and dialogue
to the existing incumbent news providers
will you still be making an occasional
appearance on spectator tv
yes i will but only if you ask me nicely
and next time
promise to provide the coffee
we're delighted to hear it thank you
andrew thank you it's great to be back
and you're doing a great job good luck
with it
[Music]
you